in a previous mass effect lore video
about the first contact war
we mentioned that in the aftermath of
the conflict a few pro-human groups
sprung up
one of those groups is cerberus which
you'll likely hear a handful of times in
mass effect 1.
it becomes a far more prominent name in
the later mass effect games
so it's worth diving into the
organization's history if you're
enjoying our mass effect lore series be
sure to like this video
subscribe to the channel as well to get
more mass effect content
like our mass effect legendary edition
video review
though cerberus isn't founded until
after the first contact war
its origins are connected to the
conflict in the final moments of the war
the turians pushed the human alliance
back to shangsuke general williams led
the resistance against the turians
enlisting the aid of three mercenaries
jack harper eva correa and ben hislop
the trio managed to capture turian
general desolus arturius
yup arturius like sarah and arturius
don't worry
we'll get to that anyway jack takes the
lead on interrogating desolace learning
that the turian is not there to take
part in the ongoing war
instead desolace is searching for an
artifact hidden in a research vessel
that crashed onto the human colonized
world in the midst of the first contact
war
using a data pad on decilis the
mercenaries mislead a group of turians
searching for the artifact into a trap
ava is assigned to watch over desolace
and the rest of the turian prisoners
while jack and ben use the turian's data
to pinpoint the location of the artifact
and go to investigate the duo find the
artifact when ben approaches it it
activates and ensnares bin in a
mysterious energy
though jack is able to pull bin away the
artifact then emits a brilliant light
the resulting explosion envelops ben
puts jack into a coma
and distracts ava just long enough for
the turian prisoners to escape
desolace captures jack and eva and takes
the still intact artifact in for steady
jack awakens weeks later under guard in
a turian prison he and eva are being
overseen by saren desola's brother
saren tells the two that the war between
the turians and humans is now over
and both jack and eva are being traded
back to the alliance
in exchange for turin prisoners not been
though because apparently
ben is dead after the exchange goes
through
jack asks general williams how he plans
to go after desolus
still facing backlash over being the
first human to ever surrender to an
alien force
william's hands are tied he can't order
an investigation into deathless even if
he wanted to
however he does give jack and eva his
personal ship and alludes the two
should go after decilis and stop him
jack starts having visions of a coming
destruction at the hands of synthetics
and tells ava that he is now
linked to the artifact he can feel its
presence and he knows it's on ilium as
humans are still new to citadel space
the two don't know how to work the
technology on ilium but then jack's eyes
begin to glow and he suddenly perfectly
understands
how to work the alien technology before
they can reach the artifact sarin and
deceleus guards ambush the pair
one is revealed to be ben still alive
and transformed into a cybernetic
creature
saren and desolace then joined the fray
capturing jack and ava once again
at this point jack's eyes have fully
transformed taking on a cybernetic
appearance
wondering why jack's transformation is
so different from ben's full-body
metamorphosis
the turians decide to bring jack and eva
back to a lab on palavin
the turian home world jack ava and ben
become the first humans to ever step
foot on the planet
jack and eva are each imprisoned
separately and jack continues to have
visions related to the artifact which
only become more vivid after he sees
a monolith that desolus is attempting to
unearth on palavin
like the artifact the monolith can
transform organics into cybernetic
creatures like ben
the monolith can just do it on a larger
scale desolace hopes to use the monolith
to transform the entire turian species
making them all into powerful cybernetic
super soldiers
eventually jack's connection to the
artifact reveals to him the truth
the monolith will enslave the turian
race not just transform them
after convincing sarin of this jack ava
and sarin team together to prevent
decilis dooming the turians
in the battle ben is killed for real
this time eva is mortally wounded the
monolith is destroyed and desolace is
knocked out
jack carries ava away and saren seals
his brother and the remains of the
monolith away in order to prevent anyone
else
learning about it following a memorial
service for ava and ben
jack comes to the revelation that
humanity is ill-prepared to handle the
threats in the milky way galaxy
which is full of more dangers than
humans realize in his mind
the only way to prevent humanity's
destruction is to ensure that humans
become the most
dominant species in the galaxy he writes
the cerberus manifesto which details his
goals for achieving human supremacy
and begins building an organization
having no idea as to the identity of the
manifesto's author
the human alliance simply refers to the
creator of cerberus as
an elusive man the name sticks and jack
harper becomes
the elusive man the elusive man
structures cerberus around the idea of
the three-headed dog of greek myth
the organization exists to protect
humanity from all threats both known
and unknown the group is divided into
three separate cells each of which is
further divided into individual
projects that are overseen by project
leads
all projects run independently of each
other reporting to the elusive man
directly
as such there's no way for one project
to rat on the rest of the organization
as evidenced by miranda lawson who is
the lead for project lazarus
not knowing about the projects behind
subject zero or the overlord vi
so if a project or an entire cellus
compromise the elusive man can cut them
off and preserve the rest of the
organization
of course this makes it somewhat easy to
take down cerberus defeat the elusive
man and the whole organization crumbles
as such the elusive man remains in
hiding secretly speaking to his project
leads on encrypted channels
not many have seen his face and even
fewer have actually spoken to him in
person
the other issue with this structure is
that cells are so independent they can
easily break off from cerberus
throughout the trilogy you'll regularly
hear about project leads that went rogue
emitting crucial details about what they
were doing in the reports to the elusive
man some leads went even further than
that like
literally traveled further you can find
cerberus operatives in mass effect
andromeda
having traveled to a whole other galaxy
to continue their work without fear of
the elusive man knowing about their
projects
though cerberus only maintains a few
projects at a time the organization has
operatives
everywhere the one exception is the
quarian migrant fleet
their distrust of outsiders and
inability to house members of other
species prevent cerberus operatives from
easily living
among them plus the quarian's
community-driven culture and loyalty to
one another prevent cerberus from paying
one of them off to be a spy
be sure to check out our lore video on
the quarians and the geth for more
information on their backstory
though cerberus works in the shadows
their name is well known by the events
of mass effect 1.
in 2165 so eight years after the first
contact war and
18 years prior to the start of mass
effect 1
cerberus became a public name when the
organization tried to steal antimatter
from the ssb geneva
an alliance cruiser five years later in
2170 in hopes of creating more human
biotics the elusive man
ordered cerberus operative paul grayson
to bomb an eldfield ashland energy
cruiser
in hopes its cargo of element zero would
blanket the colony of yandoa
and create more human biotics though the
incident caused a huge number of mental
and physical disabilities it did result
in 37 children developing biotic
abilities
deeming in an acceptable trade off
similar bombings incurred that same year
resulting in a large uptick of birth
defects as well as an increase in human
biotic births
over the next 12 years cerberus would
play a hand in several public
assassinations as well
including pope clement xvi in order to
ensure more human
leaders who approved of the cerberus
manifesto would reach political
and religious positions of power which
is why when shepard first hears the name
cerberus in 2183 the organization is
regarded by human and alien alike as a
terrorist group with racist pro-human
ideology
the elusive man and his dozen or so of
hand-picked project leads would disagree
arguing that they don't hate aliens they
largely preach that cerberus solely
exists to ensure humanity isn't stomped
out of existence
whether shepard trusts them on that is
up to you and that's the backstory into
cerberus creation
as well as the organization's brief
history between their foundation
and the events of mass effect 1. now
that mass effect legendary edition is
out and folks are playing the trilogy
again what cerberus project
most stands out in your mind when you
think of the organization for me
it's project eva responsible for the
creation of the infiltration combat mech
dr eva corey
we never learn why the elusive man named
one of his projects after one of his
dead mercenary companions
and i've always wondered let us know
what projects most stick out to you in
the comments and for more mass effect be
sure to subscribe
[Music]
you